[Music]
a victory march by farmers and their
supporters
for more than a year they fought long
and hard
unwavering unrelenting against laws they
felt were unjust
leaving family and farms behind they
camped on the borders of the indian
capital
lambasted
[Music]
he apologized and withdrew the laws
urging them to return home
but it was pressure of electoral
politics that forced the government to
compromise
agricultural reforms are desperately
needed in the country but the way the
prime minister and his government pushed
through these laws in parliament was not
acceptable by a large number of the
farming community
[Applause]
though the protests have remained
largely peaceful there were instances of
violence in january this year they
clashed with the police on their march
into the capital resulting in death and
injuries
dismantling their makeshift dwellings
and packing their belongings
they now head back home
there have been immeasurable sacrifices
but today it's a celebration of a
bittersweet victory
[Music]
never lazarus at the single border in
delhi
[Applause]